if you're looking for cut Price
Electronics look no further than the
golden computer arcade in champury pool
Hong Kong from camera equipment and
computer peripherals to game consoles
it's full of goodbyes we came just in
time to see the limited edition Legend
of Zelda tears of the kingdom and those
switch at the Nintendo store and further
down is an extensive range of computer
components and gpus on display it's
definitely cheaper to get Electronics
here because Hong Kong is tax-free
golden computer arcade is definitely
worth a visit especially for Tech and
gaming fans there are still plenty of
things to see and do here in Hong Kong
so follow us for more Adventures